Giuliani
Italy is the world's number one wine
producer but it's more than just a
commodity here in Valpolicella wine is
intrinsically Heritage culture and a way
of life that's why Ireland's plan to
slap cancer warnings on their product
has caused such shock these are crazy is
it is a over over the limits it's over
the limit under Ireland's pioneering
legislation all alcohol products not
just wine will have labels like these
warning of liver disease and the link to
fatal cancers that we know that we have
the longevity
after the Japanese is the the area with
the the maximum of longevity why that
because of the cancer they come from
they are equal come on The Vines may be
empty at this time of the year but when
you come through a region like
Valpolicella you really get a sense of
how crucial wine is to the Italian
economy it's an industry worth around 14
billion Euro a year and as employees
around 1.3 million people that's why
Italy sees this Irish plan as such a
threat we can see the these dangerous
precedent at European level and we think
that these terrifying warning labels are
not the right way to inform properly the
consumer if these will be followed but
other member states in particular they
will be very damaging for them for
Italian wine industry and exporters in
particular the Italian government is
furious the country's foreign minister
described the Irish plan as absurd and
an attack on the Mediterranean diet but
the Irish are determined to plow ahead
and they have the full support of Health
campaigners it is the first in the world
and this is why Ireland is a hero for
the rest of the world the science is
very clear alcohol causes cancer it is
about telling the truth and it's about
the people's right to know
Italians in Ireland say they're not
alone in their opposition I'm sure all
Europe Spain France eventually they're
not happy I just spoke with few wine
imparter and they told me they're all in
the same in the same boat on this the
major wine making countries say the
Irish plan is in breach of single Market
rules and it's currently being examined
by the World Trade Organization legal
action has been threatened and it seems
certain this European wine war will
continue to Bubble Stephen Murphy's Sky
News in Northern Italy